the republican party is now overtly a
christian nationalist party now the
important word here is overtly because
they've actually been a christian
nationalist party for a long time think
back you may recall
during the lead-up and during the
invasion of iraq in 2003
then president george w bush said
that god came to him with tears in his
eyes and said sir no i added that part
god came to him and said you should do
this you should invade
many times we hear policy supported or
opposed by republicans on the basis of
what is in the particular
sacred text that their particular
religion follows all of these are
elements of how these republicans would
like to see the country run
and the way they would like to see the
country run is with a sort of mix of
government and christianity now it's not
just government and religion generally
it's not government and islam it's not
government and judaism although they
will kowtow to that by saying our
judeo-christian values although remember
that jews are the most behind black
folks liberal voting group in the united
states sometimes as liberal as black
folk so the idea of judeo-christian
values is actually a cover it's a red
herring and they've been doing it for
decades so the word overtly is the
important word because now they are
brazen enough to just say it and we've
talked before about
what do we mean by christian nationalism
christian nationalism is the belief that
the united states as a country is
defined by christianity
that the government should actively
keep the country christian and keep
christianity at the center of government
many christian nationalists will
actually say that it would no longer be
america if it were no longer a christian
nation and that christianity should have
a privileged position in the public
square and it does by the way i mean at
a very superficial level
one religion gets federal holidays and
that's christianity that that's the one
out of hundreds or thousands of
religions that's the one
and thus it does have a privileged place
in american society already they used to
have to be a little bit more subtle in
their christian nationalism but no more
here are some examples from just the
last few weeks here's donald trump over
the weekend in tampa florida at the
turning point usa event talking about
americans kneel to god we are americans
and we kneel to god well not everybody
does actually and some kneel to
different gods or no god at all we will
not break we will not yield we will
never give in
we will never give up
we will never ever ever back down
as long as we are confident and united
the tyrants we are fighting
do not stand a chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and god alone
we also looked at marjorie taylor greene
radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green saying i'm a
christian nationalist that's not bad
it's actually a good thing
now if the republican party becomes a
party that actually does the same does
the things we say we're about then we
are going to be a party for nationalism
isn't that right wow
i mean she's not wrong right like it's
true they talk about the importance of
christianity in civil government and
she's saying we shouldn't just talk
about it we should act on it and she's
accurately assessing that if they acted
on the things they said we're talking
about a christian nationalist country
but then i think there's another element
we need to have and i'm a christian how
many christians do we have here
[Music]
so you see i also call myself a
christian nationalist
and that's not a bad word
that's actually a good thing right and
there's nothing wrong with leading with
your in with your faith because we
should lead with our faith because if
we're doing that then we're doing the
right thing doesn't mean we're perfect
it just means we're doing the right
thing okay and then also lauren beaubert
i mean it's all a very very similar line
lauren beaubert at some
backyard farmyard farm speech or you
know who knows where this was
saying that it is actually important for
churches to teach
how to influence and direct government
and i believe that great patriots all
throughout this nation
and christians will begin to position
themselves
in these days and these times that
pastors would have a boldness to speak
from the pulpit of their churches to
direct and inform the church on how to
influence the direction of government
and then even more overtly
she's tired of this separation of state
of church and state junk and i know some
of you have seen this clip a couple of
times now but it's important to include
it here because it is so overt the
reason we had so many over-reaching
regulations in our nation is because the
church complied
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does
now it actually is right there and it is
a
one of the top line elements of the
structure of the united states congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof it's right
there and they love to play these games
with well it's not really what the
founders meant and they were all
religious and they were christian and so
on and so forth this is one of the most
dangerous movements currently going and
unfortunately it has more oxygen than it
has in a very long time they openly now
are touting this ideology uh christian
revolt
revival christian nationalism using
their religiosity to justify homophobia
to justify transphobia to justify
sometimes racism to justify demeaning or
putting in positions uh subservient
positions other religions which is
certainly not what the founding fathers
meant so this is another layer you've
got
to go back a little bit we have like the
neocon
spread democracy layer of right wing ism
that's less present right now but it
could come back at any time that was
more under like the bush administration
you have the sort of wacky
reactionary trumpest
layer to this right wing movement which
is still present and may come back full
force depending on what happens in 2022
and 2024 but then you have the christian
nationalist element which is just as
dangerous and it is so fundamentally at
odds with what the united states is
supposed to be so what do we do well
we've got to vote i mean it's i know
it's at this point it feels almost like
not enough and also like really that's
also the solution there yeah i mean if
these people aren't in power they can't
do it it's that simple and of course
they're trying to
between gerrymandering and election uh
manipulation i guess is what we're
calling it now um they are trying to
take control even when they don't win so
just another reason why
uh the 2022 midterms are arguably the
most important that i can remember i
don't want to spend a ton of time on
this but it is important just to follow
up with some of these things you might
remember that when cassidy hutchinson
um the
uh um who worked with mark meadows
trump's former chief of staff when
cassidy hutchinson testified before the
january 6 committee and made a number of
different explosive claims about donald
trump and secret service and all these
different things there were anecdotally
messages statements from secret service
saying that's not true and we're willing
to testify under oath and the january 6
committee said great come in and testify
under oath and then they didn't why
haven't they done it well
we have to sort of speculate a little
bit but here is adam kinzinger one of
the few republicans on the january 6
committee saying
we haven't been able to talk to them i
mean listen they said
they said we'll talk to you and they
just don't come in um so we want answers
to that
we heard through anonymous sources in
the media that the secret service agents
you know present when uh cassidy
hutchison talked about the heated
argument in the the limo the president's
beast uh that they were eager to talk to
us we haven't been able to talk to them
yet either
we have our doors wide open they just
have to do it under oath so that on top
of again
we just have a lot of people coming
forward with pieces of the puzzle maybe
pieces of information maybe cassidy
hutchison or sarah matthews inspired
them
and so we're going to work on beginning
to write our report but keep this
investigation wide open and getting more
and more information so listen they all
came forward a bunch of them came
forward and they said we're willing to
testify secret service agent reportedly
willing to testify trump did not lunge
at him this is from the guardian and
this was right after the testimony of
cassidy hutchinson and then a bunch of
different other media outlets reported
on this cnn and other outlets reported
the pushback on the alleged secret
service incident from tony ornato also a
deputy chief of staff in the trump white
house robert engel trump's security
chief and on and on and on
and the committee members said we
welcome you to be here under oath of
course and but really cassidy hutchinson
was under oath
what is the value of secret service
agents showing up not under oath and
refuting the claims let's get everybody
under oath so then we can actually say
we have conflicting under oath
statements we continue to have
only one set of claims made under oath
and of course it wasn't surprising to me
i've been tweeting about it for weeks
they haven't testified why haven't they
testified we don't know
um
they're law enforcement one would think
they don't have an issue in principle
with being under oath
but if you won't testify under oath
about the things you saw while working
for the secret service
to me that's a red flag and of course in
courts of law we don't consider people
silence as indicative of guilt but when
you come out and you say we'll testify
we'll talk about it we didn't see what
cassidy hutchinson said and then you're
welcomed great show up take an oath just
like she did and tell us what you saw
and then they're missing it is
completely reasonable in the court of
public opinion to say
maybe they weren't telling the truth and
maybe cassidy hutchinson is one other
note on the cassidy hutchinson testimony
um pat sipoloni
the former white house counsel
uh in his under oath testimony
he didn't dispute the things that
cassidy hutchinson said
with some he claimed privilege attorney
client privilege with donald trump with
some he did a sort of i don't recall or
i can't necessarily speak to that but
he went under oath and didn't refute any
of the things that cassidy hutchinson
said so still waiting for the secret
service agents to come in
not surprising that they haven't and i
don't expect them to follow me on
twitter at dpakman let me know what you
make of the latest absence of secret
service agents who were just weeks ago
so ready to testify
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program please
consider yourselves invited to sign up
at
joinpackman.com we do an extra show
every single day for our members called
the bonus show we also offer a
commercial free audio and video feed of
the show every day to our members
including making it available five or
six hours earlier then the show is
published to everybody else and you also
get priority access to david pakman show
town halls like the one we are holding
tonight july 26th at 6 p.m eastern i
hope to see
many of you there you can sign up at
i have two clips that i'm going to play
for you here that are one very very
significant in terms of what it suggests
is happening legally in washington dc
right now and two one which is just
absolutely hilarious it's a sort of mic
drop moment related to matt gates and
his alleged uh child sex trafficking the
videos involve an individual named mark
short now mark short was former vice
president mike pence's former chief of
staff
uh he we have now learned has been um uh
brought under subpoena and testified
before a washington dc federal grand
jury investigating january 6. why is
this a big deal it's a big deal i'm not
quizzing you i'll tell you i i don't ask
it rhetorically it's a big deal because
as the january sixth house committee has
been doing its work we've been wondering
aloud is the department of justice
investigating any or some or all of the
things that we've learned from the
january 6 committee or are they even
seriously investigating at a higher
level
um the events of january 6th we know
that there are hundreds of individual
defendants for their personal roles on
january 6th but there's a broader
question as to whether the bigger
picture of the way that trump and the
people around him incited the riots is
being investigated by merrick garland
the fact that mark short was under
subpoena and appeared before a federal
grand jury in washington dc
at least suggests that the answer is yes
so the funny clip is the second one
let's look at this first he didn't say
much but this is a major confirmation
i can confirm that i did receive a
subpoena for the federal grand jury and
i comply with that subpoena but under
advice of counsel i really can't say
much more than that
that was my only appearance before the
grand jury
i'm not going to comment what others on
the team have had to testify or not
regarding subpoenas and what they've
testified to this suggests it doesn't
prove but it certainly suggests and what
else might it mean it's hard to think of
something else this indicates
that the federal government the justice
department is now investigating january
6th at a bigger and higher level
than simply individuals who were at the
capitol on that day that's a major major
thing
also during an interview with cnn short
was asked about matt gates's comments
over the weekend
and short delivers an absolutely brutal
takedown of gates the look on cnn anchor
aaron burnett's face sort of says it all
here check this out
our america
is proudly
ultra magga not some low energy roadside
rhino safari
on that note let me just say what
everybody here knows
mike pence will never be president
nice guy
not a leader
mark
well i don't know if mike pence will run
for president 2024 but
i don't think matt gates will have an
impact on that in fact i'd be surprised
if he was still voting it's more likely
he'll be in prison for child sex
trafficking by 2024 and i'm actually
surprised that florida law enforcement
still allows them to speak to teenage
conferences like that so i'm not too
worried about matt gates thanks yeah
shocking that law enforcement even
allows matt gates against around people
under age 18. so listen
absolutely hilarious
perfectly delivered and in all
seriousness matt gates might get away
with absolutely
nothing happening to him and no
consequences whatsoever for the alleged
crimes that he has been involved in the
the question is what the hell is taking
so long i actually remember
when i first learned that matt gates was
under investigation for child sex
trafficking it was march of 2021 i
remember because it was my first trip
sort of like in the covid era i remember
exactly where i was i was about to go
out to the beach and i glanced at my
phone and saw gates is now under
investigation and it was the night that
gates appeared on tucker carlson's show
and gave that bizarre interview where he
was like tucker you've met the woman
supposedly i trafficked remember we went
to dinner and tucker was like i have no
memory of that whatsoever don't pull me
into this thing that was the start of it
that was now
16 months ago 16 months ago so is it is
it uh unusual that it can take this long
for investigations to be done no it's
not unusual
is it starting to get to the point where
it's reasonable to wonder what's going
on and are they even going to charge
gates with anything yes it is getting to
that point so good for mark short for
just saying what we're all thinking how
is this guy even still around allowed
around young girls absolutely well
delivered and it's all great and
everything but it is not obvious to me
whatsoever that there are actually going
to be any consequences for matt gates
and of course these are alleged things
that he did if the evidence doesn't show
that he did them then he should not be
charged we this is not a show where i
demand people be charged for things they
didn't do what we're aware of is that
matt gates alleged co-conspirator
um certainly has acknowledged doing a
whole bunch of the stuff that he and
gates are accused of and so now it
starts to stretch
our credulity when we say well so the
other guy did all the stuff and he's
admitting it but we're supposed to
believe gates actually wasn't involved
in it when there's that
it's abundantly clear that they know
each other and that they were involved
in this stuff together starts to get
hard to believe but we will follow it
and hopefully mark short is correct
we talked last week
about fox news starting to set up
support of ron desantis for president in
2024 support for ron desantis is the
republican nominee in 2024 and an
abandonment of bailing out
a uh uh an escape from support for
former president donald trump and we
played some clips in fact from fox news
that indicated that they're not saying
we would we would support a democrat
over trump but fox news seems to be very
clearly positioning itself to support
someone other than trump in the primary
donald trump has now completely flipped
out on fox and friends
because fox and friends simply
acknowledged there are polls that show
ron desantis ahead of donald trump for
the 2024 republican primary they didn't
even say we prefer desantis they didn't
say trump sucks they didn't say sir we
don't want you anymore they just said
there are polls in which desantis is
leading and trump
raging on truth central at fox and
friends so let's look first at the clip
and this is so milk toast this is so
banal it's just
there are polls that say desantis is
doing better you've got people from all
across the country convening in tampa
i am thinking about um
that is a little different than a couple
of other polls that we've seen over the
last couple of weeks two weeks ago in
florida blue point
rather blueprint polling did a poll
desantis leads the former president in
all age groupings
then there was a university of new
hampshire poll in june
desantis actually led trump 39 to 37 and
that uh new york times sienna a college
poll that we've cited quite a few times
less than half of republican voters back
donald trump as their preferred choice
so it's like the young people who are
activists at that event right
like the former president but looking at
these other polls
a different answer yeah if you look
state by state ron desantis is showing
tremendous strength in new hampshire
michigan and florida tremendous strength
he's leading or tied with the former
president uh and turning point run by
charlie kirk extremely impressive
organization and they are extremely
enthusiastic and active
yeah so
pretty milk toast guys it's like trump's
doing well in some places but desantis
as well in others and there's some polls
in which desantis is either tied or
leading that's just what it is these are
just facts and donald trump triggered on
his platform truth social truth central
by any suggestion that maybe
someone in the republican party might
vote for somebody else trump posting
almost immediately
fox and friends just really botched my
poll numbers no doubt on purpose why
would they botch it on purpose well i
guess if you think that they're starting
to build a campaign against you you
would think that that show has been
terrible gone to the dark side they
quickly quote the big turning point poll
victory of almost 60 points over the
number two republican and then hammer me
with outliers actually almost all polls
have me leading all republicans and
biden by a lot
rhino paul ryan one of the weakest and
worst speakers ever
must be running the place anyway
thank you to turning point the crowd and
love was amazing this is exactly what
we've been hoping for fracture the party
let them tear themselves apart destroy
the party and an important reminder on
this fox news thing
just because fox is setting itself up to
probably turn on trump and support
desantis in the republican primary that
doesn't actually mean fox news number
one has the power to turn the republican
party against donald trump and it also
doesn't mean that if trump is the
nominee in 24 that fox won't get in line
and support him over whoever is the
democratic nominee obviously they will
let's take those two things one at a
time
in 2016 donald trump won the republican
primary with fox against him from the
get-go it was a long primary in 2016 for
the republican party it started in 2015
in fact and there were
18 16 candidates some large number of
candidates donald trump started polling
almost nothing early
fox news did not support trump for the
absolute longest time eventually when
donald trump had gained a bunch of
momentum
by attrition as the one two three
percent candidates dropped out
and trump was able to start coalescing
support and the evangelicals eventually
reluctantly came over to trump after he
told some story about how he's against
abortion now
fox news eventually acquiesced but they
were against trump and trump still won
so first of all it's not clear fox
really has the power to torpedo the
trump pres trump uh uh candidacy in the
republican primary secondly um trump is
going to continue doing his rallies
um finding ways to reach most of his
base even without fox news necessarily
on his side even without being on
twitter so that's not going to be a
problem and maybe the most important
thing is in the end fox news is going to
get in line and fox news will get in
line for two reasons one fox can't
support a democrat
that would completely torpedo their
brand that wouldn't make any sense
whatsoever so fox actually really has no
choice of eventually supporting whoever
is the republican nominee even if the
republican nominee were eventually like
an uh over white nationalist or
something like that
fox would still not support the democrat
they might maybe not not super
aggressively support the republican
candidate maybe they would
but fox has a business model that's
based on we support republicans um and
then number two
uh there is going to be some point at
which it will be clear who the nominee
is going to be it's very unlikely that
the nomination will be contested until
the very end
uh it's just not usually that way
usually before the media calls it we
kind of in the analysis space reasonable
people we go it's pretty damn clear
who's gonna be the nominee
and um that is going to give fox lead
time to in some
credible to their audience way it might
not be credible to you and i but in some
way that is sort of credible to the
republican fox news viewer
jump ship to whoever is going to be the
nominee because they can't lose out on
access that's one of the most important
things for a network like fox news you
have to maintain access to the
republican nominee who may eventually be
the president that's their most
important thing that's their business
model we'll have these clips on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show we will take a quick break
and be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow it's great to welcome
back to the program today jack barski
who's a retired and reformed
ex-undercover kgb agent also author of
the great book deep undercover my secret
life entangled allegiances as a kgb spy
in america which we spoke with him about
in some detail last time and uh which
i've read and can recommend to you jack
great to have you back on today
well
i'm delighted to be back
so i think one of the things that would
be interesting to get your thoughts on
would be that there is so much
speculation and pontificating on the
sort of psychology of putin and what has
driven this particular invasion of
ukraine at this particular time
everything from illness to a desire to
restore the former ussr to its former
glory to everything in between has been
sort of cited
how are you kind of thinking about the
last few months that have taken place
there militarily
well we were talking about the timing
[Music]
he's an opportunist
he perceives weakness
in the american government and
up until he did the invasion there was
uh
quite a bit of weakness within nato
you know
if you remember that uh
uh there's this controversial uh action
that donald trump took when he went uh
to europe to nato and told him to pay up
already and pay their the share that
they promised because they were all
under paying
and so uh putin has never made a secret
out of his long-term plan
it's just the west that didn't didn't
pay attention to it didn't take it
seriously as
as
particularly the u.s intelligence
services were
focused on
fighting terrorism
and pretty much ignored what's going on
in russia now we had a
reset with russia which was asinine
uh when it didn't work
uh that was under obama and and then you
know and then trump was uh you know
blowing smoke
uh but but there wasn't really
uh
a recognition that there's there's some
some real chance that this is going to
blow
uh so and it was i forgot when it was
but sometime
uh in the in the late uh
2010s to 2015 or so uh putin actually
openly declared at a conference in
europe where there were heads of state
that uh his mission is to
reinstate
a greater russia not the soviet union
uh he he is focused on
on this slavic speaking people that
would
eventually include poland and the czech
republic and uh and a few others but but
he wants you know he's looking at
the russia that peter the great ruled
that wasn't a great country either but
you know uh it's
peter the great
is an icon in russian history and and uh
this this is
you know putin wants to be
uh
seen as the success of peter the great
good luck peter the great was uh six
feet seven tall putin is not
reaching
um so um
uh and
and and most recently two years ago
there was a
an essay was
published uh by russian media
it was published by also in english
where he quite and it was was signed
the author is vladimir putin whether he
was the order or not whether or not it
was signed it was published in his name
where he clearly
restated his long-term goal
and so when he invaded crimea
uh that was um
five years ago i believe and and the
west didn't didn't even
uh
you know
sneeze
there was nothing going on he said well
now is the time to to go into ukraine
and expand our reach that's that's
pretty much my my view on things
one of the um
things that has surprised some is that
it appears as though
russia may have misjudged the degree and
the scope of ukrainian resistance and
what seems maybe surprising about that
is that russia is known for a quite
extensive
intelligence service kgb which you're
very much familiar with other
departments as well
what how could something that from the
outside random people were saying you
know there might be more resistance than
is assumed how how could such an
extensive intelligence apparatus
misjudge that if they did
okay first of all uh the entire world uh
misjudged
the the will of the ukrainians to fight
okay because nobody's really paying
attention nobody's paying attention to
history uh that there has been a
uh
intrinsic hatred of of russia everything
russian coming out of ukraine
and uh one of one of the worst things
that
actually
uh
is is still sticking in ukrainian's
minds the history where stalin
went
into ukraine in in the early 30s and and
and confiscated all the grain and over
four million ukrainians starved
uh
to death
and that is in the part of the world
that is the most fertile
period uh this one this was because the
stalin wanted to force collectivization
so and so and and there's one thing
you got you got to understand is if you
invade a country
where
everybody is a soldier not just the men
but the women and the children you will
not in the long run win that war we
found that out in vietnam
we found it out in afghanistan
okay so uh but with regard to
intelligence services that's a that's a
very interesting subject
i
i guarantee you there are undercover
agents
of the ukraine in russia and vice versa
there's a lot of misleading going on
they can't because they uh
ukrainians are bilingual almost all of
them and russians have no problem uh
learning
to speak ukrainian uh because it's just
very very similar so you get you get
intelligence you don't know if it's real
or it's from a double agent
and it goes both ways
uh and and and the other thing is
assuming that putin got some decent
intelligence
uh
maybe his his intelligence opera
apparatus the gru primarily uh had the
right information
did you see that tape
where uh
putin
is is just treating the head of the svr
the another intelligence service like a
fourth grader yes
that guy was shaking in his boots so you
know you may not want to give the boss
bad news
and and if you have the courage to do so
the boss may just say you know you're
full of
sorry
so so it's a it's a very fluid situation
there um
and and if if the russians didn't have
the right intelligence
you know you can't blame the cia either
right you know one of the um things that
i gathered from
reading your book uh and reading about
um
other
sometimes double agents former kgb etc
that there seems to be a certain level
of paranoia
within uh the apparatus that includes if
i recall correctly an entire department
that just
observes and verifies that kgb agents
are not working for some other
intelligence service with that level
of paranoia
what can you deduce about the images for
example of putin sitting
40 feet away from advisors at a table
and and to talk a little bit about like
the psychology of what happens behind
the scenes uh the the paranoia is uh
is
inherited
you know that
during the reign of stalin
there were periodic purges
within the military within the
intelligence services because stalin was
the ultimate uh paranoid individual
and uh and and so
this just became part of the dna of
of uh
the russian army and the and the
and the intelligence services
because
you know
when the soviet union fell apart in the
kgb was
dissolved and became
three different intelligence services
um
who
trained the new guys who trained the
ones that are now in charge is that it's
the old kgb and they had paranoia in
their blood
and and
in general the
uh the the
the russian dna period
it has a paranoid gene
and that's justified
uh
the russian state was formed in the
middle ages and ever since it
came into being it was always invaded
from the north the vikings came in from
the east to mongrel from the west it was
napoleon and from the south it was the
turks
so they were constantly under siege
and uh so and that by the way that is uh
a
platform that or you know a history that
putin is using
to
uh tell his people that whatever
is wrong with russia is all
it's the west fault it's the fault of
nato it's the fault of the united states
and uh the the united states and nato
can't wait
to just conquer russia and
and and you know kill the russian spirit
and and destroy the russian nation and
they they have bought it
they actually have bought it uh uh and
if you know people have ruminated in
public you know what what would it take
to get rid of vladimir putin you don't
even want to try because you think you
get rid of putin that russia will change
the the russian
nation
is severely contaminated
and and decontamination
is a hard thing to do the the allied
founded out
uh when when they tried to
get the nazi ideology out of every
german brain after world war ii it took
forever and was not in every case of
successful that's interesting because
while certainly what you say is true
it also seems as though even
within some of putin's top generals
they're not necessarily thrilled about
this incursion into ukraine and to some
degree it does feel to me that if putin
was killed or died there would not be
the same interest in continuing this
that there is from putin you you think
that it would not change
well you're talking about the generals
you know
and this is speculative but uh it seems
to make sense the the russian army has
uh had a lot of losses that weren't
anticipated and so if you're a general
and and you
you're uh
you're involved in that invasion
uh you can see that
the russian army is being weakened to
some degree okay
uh but
don't
the
there there are enough hawks
in the putin uh regime underneath putin
to continue
what he started and the russian people
will
will not get out in the streets and
demonstrate and
stop this war they will not because they
know it's necessary you understand also
uh the the whole um
the whole canard that uh
russia is fighting nazis
it's partially true
in what sense
yes sir
uh and i i give you
just one item one fact that uh
you never heard in in the mainstream
media you know who stefan bandera was no
stefan bandera was a ukrainian nazi he
had a
he he was uh
he led a nazi-type movement and when
hitler came he joined hitler uh
with his troops and there were a lot of
ukrainian uh
guards in concentration camps and people
ukrainians who participate participated
in uh
in
killing jews okay that's a historic fact
so now here comes the interesting uh
afterthought
two years ago it was step on bandera's
100th birthday
the ukrainian government
issued commemorative stamps to honor him
now there has to be some nazis right and
even up in the government now
zielinski is not a nazi for sure and i
don't
believe the country is is a nazi country
but but you see if you if you uh want to
sell a big lie
if you have a kernel of truth it's so
much easier to assume
uh jack how do you see this war
concluding because there's the idea that
it will only conclude either when putin
is given an exit that allows him to save
face or he dies
uh it will not stop when he dies uh i'm
convinced this will go on
for a long time it's a war of attrition
so far zielinski has uh indicated that
he is not going to give an acre of land
so until
unless he is is willing to say okay i'm
going to let go of donbass uh because
there's too too many ukrainians dying
uh but um
i uh i have a a friend who who hails
from that region and he was in an
intelligence in russia and he he knows
he has a really good understanding of
what drives ukrainians they are fighting
not for land they're fighting for their
uh freedom
and for their uh their existence as a
nation
and as long as
that is as long as they're willing to
fight
to the death
that that whole war is going to go on
for a long time god forbid even if
russia takes all of ukraine and occupies
it you know what you're going to have a
guerrilla war like in vietnam and
in afghanistan so uh there's no at this
point there's no end inside you you you
so the idea that in three months
as a result of negotiations this could
essentially come to an end you don't
think there's even a chance of that
they're not talking at all right
but i mean even you just don't even
think that that's a plausible scenario
period
not not not in the near future not not
in the next several months uh the the uh
situation
in the field would have to change
dramatically to
go one way or the other
is there some level of death and
destruction for the russian forces that
would get putin to say we have to cut
our losses and retreat or is that not in
his dna
i
he's on a one-way street okay and uh he
he will
he will pulverize the entire country if
he can and has to
well
uh we've been speaking with jack barsky
we're uh linking to his book uh retired
and reformed ex-undercover kgb agent uh
jack always great speaking with you
appreciate your time yeah may i may i
just add the the fact that uh there's
also
a podcast out there it's called the
agent it's an
audio documentary it's very well done
and if you don't want to read the whole
book uh the story
is in that podcast and it's uh it's also
told not just by me but by a lot of
people who were important in my life
that's amazing i recommend the book but
the podcast sounds like it's a way to
get a lot a lot of the same story as
well thanks jack appreciate it thank you
bye-bye
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
so on the bonus show today we are going
to talk about steve bannon's conviction
on two counts of contempt of congress
but what i want to talk about here is
that even after this conviction and you
gotta say he is certainly acting with
conviction he went back on his program
and started talking about shock troops
deconstructing the government brick by
brick more coded language that sounds
very much like an insurrectious coup uh
steve bannon calls on four thousand
shock troops to deconstruct the
government brick by brick he's back with
more incendiary rhetoric against the
nation days after his contempt of
congress conviction
check out this clip and understand that
he's calling for treason again
and there are people who listen to this
guy
and who act based on what he says
and these are not
accidental phrases that he's using this
is all very specifically targeted to
have a particular impact on the people
that hear it take a listen to this
we're talking about a republican
democracy because essentially we have
taken on the model
of really davos and the chinese
communist party of an authoritarian
state undemocratic with institutions
that are not democratic now understand
that
we're going to listen to the entire
thing
but
this is one of those oh the democrats
are going to do voter fraud and really
they tried to steal an election they
didn't win
one of the principles of traditional
conservatism
is small government now we know that in
many ways they never really adhered to
it they're like small government but
let's decide who can get married small
government but let's decide what medical
procedures women can have okay we know
that it was bs all along
but while continuing to claim that they
are against authoritarianism
they are increasingly using government
as a way to achieve what they want
rather than allowing markets or public
opinion
or culture or whatever to make decisions
they want
whenever they see something they don't
like
they want courts up to and including the
supreme court to just make decisions
that favor them we saw this when it came
to the 2020 election didn't win an
election well just start filing lawsuits
and get courts and judges in the supreme
court if you're lucky enough to decide
that you actually get to be president
anyway
when it comes to abortion ban ban pass a
ban get the supreme court to overturn
ban it at the state level ban it at the
federal level ban uh contraception
or access to it or
standard access to it without a copay as
part of health insurance they
increasingly are the ones trying to use
state power to achieve their goals but
bannon insists that it's the left that
wants to do that
and state capitalism
now how do you combat that
you combat that by deconstructing you
have to take it apart brick by brick
you know steve uh it gets my deplorable
blood going on a monday morning to hear
jonathan swann talk about a purge a
purge of the administrative state now of
course he means that to be an expose and
to be a hit on our movement we take it
exactly the opposite and wear it as a
badge of honor and it tells me that yes
uh jonathan swann recognizes that there
is a plan in place that this second
trump term is going to be far more
consequential than the first one and the
first one was quite consequential
article three let me get um mike and
we're gonna have a one hour special
on the jonathan swann
axios articles i want everybody to
understand
deeply
exactly what we're doing here okay
exactly what's going on because you're
going to be part of it
and particularly what people it's coming
stepping forward and say hey i i want to
be one of those 4 000 shock troops or
there's going to be lots of other
opportunities lots of other
opportunities lots of opportunities for
treason want to be a shock troop and
what exactly shock troops do of course
is nebulous and uh he's calling for
treason again and and the point here of
using the various euphemisms
is for plausible deniability right
deconstruct the administrative state
okay well that's just basically taking
apart
centers of power in government by
eliminating departments and that doesn't
sound violent does it well though it's
not in and of itself but it's all part
of this idea that they need
shocking
action and when you talk about troops of
course you're alluding to force and
military force and weapons and all of
these different things this was a term
coined by steve steve bannon this is all
meant to keep them all ginned up and at
the ready to do whatever it is that you
need them to do and by them i'm talking
of course about the supporters the
patsies who end up
uh prosecuted right who end up
prosecuted after the january six riots
while donald trump flies around giving
speeches so uh one other clip that i
want to look at here and uh he's using
we're going to kill the administration
in the crib that's another phrase that
bannon loves to use we said we'd kill
this in the crib now we were just a
small part of it but remember we've been
maniacally focused
since we talked friends we're going to
kill this administration in the crib hey
i don't care if benny thompson doesn't
like that and nancy pelosi doesn't like
it or who doesn't like it justin
department i don't care if you don't
like it suck on it we're destroying this
illegitimate regime yeah sort of weird
by the way that people who claim to be
pro-life you talk about killing things
in the crib as if that's a good thing to
do but let's put that aside for a moment
these are extraordinarily dangerous and
violent ideas that's one side to this
but i also don't want to ignore the
likely cynical reality that there's a
fundraising aspect to this thing
somewhere
there there is almost certainly
some motivation
in this new plan
that bannon starts to talk about now uh
which which seems to be wrapped up with
what many are writing is an imminent
announcement of a 2024 candidacy by
donald trump there's probably some
fundraising element to it as well
notice also that at one previous point
in time steve bannon promised twenty
thousand shock troops now he's down to
four thousand maybe recruiting isn't
going particularly well but this is what
happens when you don't properly punish a
coup attempt and make sure that
everybody knows that even at the top
level there's going to be consequences
yes the patsies in the capital
they got arrested they're getting
charged some of them are going to prison
but if you don't punish the people at
the top level it's going to continue and
you will see it stop when either
the leaders are properly punished or the
coup succeeds and that latter option
would be very very bad and of course the
fear is with a 6-3 supreme court in your
favor
that the success of the coup will take
place in 2024 going into 2025 bannon's
dangerous bannon should be in prison but
even being in prison where he will
likely spend some time or jail will find
out about that his sentencing is in
october
he still will likely be able to wield
influence and one of the things judges
are supposed to do when they sentence
individuals
is consider whether they're remorseful
and consider whether they're likely to
break the law again
steve bannon is not remorseful and steve
bannon is openly saying he is going to
continue getting involved in all sorts
of of horrible things
uh he's itching to do more harm and he
should get the maximum sentence he'll
probably end up with the minimum which i
believe is 30 days
um i have an incredible story for you
here
this is a story not only of of uh
potential domestic violence sadly
but also yet again of the projection
that is
they are going to commit voter fraud
we have now learned of a man whose wife
is missing and he is a suspect in her
disappearance
who has pled guilty to casting her
ballot for trump in 2020
this is the voter fraud that they claim
exists exclusively on the left and yet
law enforcement seems to only be able to
find republicans committing voter fraud
the hill reports
man with missing wife
pleads guilty to casting her ballot for
trump in 2020
a man who was tried in connection to his
wife's disappearance pleaded guilty
thursday to submitting a fraudulent
ballot on her behalf for trump during
the 2020 election this is barry more few
who said to law enforcement he figured
all these other guys are cheating
my wife suzanne would have voted for
trump so i'm going to submit a ballot
for her
the defendant was arrested in may of
2021 but was already in police custody
because of his suspected role in his
wife's disappearance
okay the suspicion is he killed his wife
morpheu was offered a plea deal allowing
charges of attempting to influence a
public servant and elections offense to
be dropped if he plea pled guilty to the
forgery charge he faces a year of
supervised probation for the charge
uh the murder case against barry morphy
was dismissed without prejudice after
suzanne morphy's body was unable to be
located so understand that we have no
particular reason to think he didn't
kill his wife
there just was no body and in this
particular case there was not enough of
a circumstantial case sometimes you see
murder cases go forward with nobody
and sometimes you even see guilty
verdicts with no body but in this case
there was no such case to be made
suzanne morphy disappeared in may of
2020 and has not been recovered however
law enforcement said last year they
believe they are close to discovering
the victim's body think about that he
said to law enforcement listen uh
everybody else is cheating i know my
wife would have voted for trump
so i decided to submit the vote for her
anyway that's a crime okay
uh maybe the wife didn't really want to
vote for trump and he killed her
and then voted for trump in her name
maybe we don't really know
understand the projection that is
constantly happening republican leaders
and trump spend 2020 saying there is
massive fraud happening by by democrats
and so some republican voters say screw
it if the democrats are going to cheat
we're going to cheat too
and then law enforcement shows up and
says we don't find any democrats doing
this we only are able to find
republicans doing this some to quote
test the system
and some because they are just genuinely
committing voter fraud the very voter
fraud that they say it is the left that
is that that uh is being committed by
the left these people are incredible and
if they are allowed to do it again
they will and if they're able to succeed
we're really screwed
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is a caller
accurately identifying that right
wingers are better than left wingers at
firing up their bases
hello david uh great show listen all the
time this is brent and my question is
it seems like every weekend the
republicans and the mega
radicals are holding a rally either a
trump rally or a cpac rally or a turning
point rally
it says rally after rally after a rally
however you don't see any of this on the
left
is that a bigger problem
or
am i the only one that thinks that the
problem that
the right has all these ridiculous
rallies that seems to rile up the base
and the left has nothing to counter that
i have been saying this for years the
pyrotechnics
the wrestling style introductions the
explosive music everything
it's all pathetically cringe-worthy and
we all recognize it as such
and also
it is more of the evidence it's more
it's it's these are greater and greater
examples
of how the right creates community
and funds this stuff
to activate and engage and inspire and
fire people up in a way that the left
does not now i'm not suggesting that we
try to fire people up in the exact same
way i mean a lot of this stuff
it
it appeals to the right more than it
appeals to the left so i'm not saying we
do the same thing but the left would
greatly benefit from a decision
that we have to pour more money into
activating engaging and inspiring people
and if we don't
we're going to lose the ground game and
we continue to lose it in many ways so
yeah the caller is a hundred percent
correct on today's bonus show pac-man's
a loser i know alex jones hates the
bonus show we are going to talk about
steve bannon's two guilty counts and his
likely sentence we are going to talk
about new sex education books rejected
by a florida school board and we will
talk about support from two-thirds of
americans for term limits in the supreme
court all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com